important question how far were the
earth stretch if you cut it into one
meter cubes just like in minecraft and
lay them end to end in a long line
through space well as it happens there's
a giant Minecraft project underway to
recreate the entire Earth within the
game's universe at a one-to-one scale
but instead of asking them to
deconstruct this earth and layout and
align to answer this question we can
just calculate it and let me tell you it
is way further than you might think
and that's because volumes are super
underrated and this was something which
occurred to me when I was debating with
someone over the classic question of
whether it's ever okay to pee in a
swimming pool
now who is arguing for which side isn't
important but basically one was claiming
that it's an atrocious thing to do
because then everyone's getting covered
in your pee and the other side simply
pointed out that it's not actually the
case because when you compare it to the
volume of water held in the average
swimming pool it becomes so insanely
diluted that it's basically negligible
and so to settle this we ran the numbers
and based on a standard 25 metre pool
that is 10 meters wide and 1.3 meters
deep then that contains 325 cubic meters
of water and now compare this to the
average urination volume of I don't know
a 5 foot 5 50 kilogram female which
Google suggests is about 0.3 of a liter
and then compare the two and that equals
a ratio of over 1 million to 1 it's like
if you take one milliliter of orange
juice this example and add it to 100
milliliters of water shake that up then
take one milliliter of that add it to a
second hundred millilitres and then do
it a third time I mean by this point
this is so diluted the blanket let alone
worrying about having it on your skin in
fact it's about as dangerous for you as
homeopathy is good for you because by
the way dilution is what homeopathy is
all about the idea that the more dilute
a substance is the more of a positive
effect it has on your body and in fact
whenever you see one of those 30 C
labels on a bottle of homeopathy what
that means is that they've done this
hundred to one dilution process 30 times
in a row which corresponds to one part
in 10 to the 60 and means that you are
almost certainly without a shadow of a
doubt can see me exactly zero molecules
of whatever belladonna or arsenic it you
think that you should be ingesting but
anyway my point is is that volumes are
incredibly underrated and nothing
demonstrates this better than this
question of how far the Earth's volume
would stretch if you cut it into one
meter cubes and lay them out in a long
line through space now if you want to
pause and calculate it then go ahead but
first what does your gut say do you
think you could stretch to the moon how
about 150 million kilometers to the Sun
well the answer is it would stretch the
entire way across the Milky Way yeah I
couldn't believe it myself but the earth
contains roughly as many cubic meters in
it as the diameter of our entire galaxy
a galaxy that contains around 250
billion stars and is so big it takes
light the fastest thing in the universe
over a hundred thousand years to cross
and just put that into perspective our
nearest star system Alpha Centauri is
only four light years away but that's
still a distance so vast that if the Sun
was a tennis ball in Los Angeles
Alpha Centauri would be another tennis
ball in Dallas Texas 2,000 kilometers
away and if you find this hard to wrap
your head around you're not alone
because all of our instincts really just
evolved to deal with linear
relationships where things scan up in a
proximate proportion to one another but
because volume operates in three
dimensions the ratio between it and the
length of the object scales up cubic
leaves and cubic grows wasn't a
calculation we really needed to know
when we were running around on the
savanna
what do you call it is the smaller the
size of cubes that you cut a volume up
into to lay out in a line the further
that line stretches because there are
exponentially more of those cubes and in
fact there's a size of cube you could
cut the earth into so then it stretches
across the entire observable universe
sorry for you next nerds night
excellent now that that pressing matter
has been sorted out let's get back to
our original problem which was the 1
meter wide galaxy length earth minecraft
bridge which I'm sure you will agree is
a rather annoying object like if a Milky
Way was a moving fan trying to maneuver
it then it's so long you could barely
close the doors but if we arrange these
cubes into a 2d square then there's no
longer an issue it only stretches 1/5 of
the way to the Sun but then again we do
now have a whole new problem because
compared to the scale of the galaxy van
the square is roughly only the size of a
single atom and of course if we arrange
the earth back into three dimensions
then it's now back to being the size of
the earth which at the scale of the van
means that it'll be some weird subatomic
a ball of essentially nothing so it's
probably time I just abandon this
analogy but my point is the more
dimensions you go up the more compact
the earth becomes because there are more
and more directions you can cram it all
into and what if we keep going with this
into a higher dimension so you know like
what would happen if you fold the earth
up into a four dimensional view well as
I discovered in sort of researching this
topic hyper dimensionality and the
behavior of 3d objects when you put them
into four dimensional space is this huge
counterintuitive mess of like manifolds
and things being smushed over surfaces
and turned inside-out and rabbit holes
of holographic universes and all that
fun stuff so I will save that for the
next video in this series but thank you
so much for watching and if you enjoyed
this then obviously please do subscribe
because I imagine the next one will
tickle tickle tickle your fantasy to
tickle oh yes and one more thing please
do not ever use this video as an excuse
to well you know because as it turns out
it's the urea in your urine that reacts
with the chlorine and the pool to create
this really grim compound known as tri
chlorine and it's tri chloramine that
actually stings your eyes and skin and
gives swimming pools that chlorine II
smell sorry they actually meant to be
completely odorless until people pee in
them so just remember that next time you
smell that nostalgic smell and
yeah so don't do it because it's like
it's the tragedy of the Commons and
that's bad games it's like a very bad
example of game theory I should make a
bunch of videos on that hmm